Well, on that note...
why don't we go ahead and see who got the first pick?
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
House Cavs!
Oh, yes! F--k you, Lebron!
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
House Suns!
Oh, YEAH!
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
House Knicks!
-Oh, yeah!
-I'm going to sell this house for so much gold!
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
House Bulls!
OH, YES! So many cool dunks!
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
House Hawks!
Aw, yeah! Skrt skrt!
House Mavericks!
YES! QUADRUPLE DIRKS!
House Wizards!
OH, YES! Let’s sign that supermax, Ern—whoever!
House Hornets!
YES!
House Grizzlies!
Well, that's nice!
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
Oh, my god...
House Lakers!
House Heat!
Oh, yeah!
House Timberwolves!
Oh...cool cool. That’s nice.
And the winner of the Zion lottery is...
Oh, boy
House Kings!
-Which means their pick goes to the Sixers…
-No. No. No.
Oh, f--k. Are you f--king kidding me?